it's not my job to tell
the true story of prince charles that's
not what we're doing at all the crown
can't ever be factually perfect but it
sure is an emotional rollercoaster
especially for the actors involved while
we hope they will do season 5 justice
today we are reflecting on the moments
that they struggled the most to film
number one sometimes beginning is the
hardest part i'm imelda staunton and i'm
currently on the set of the crown while
season five was just in its beginning
stages imelda was feeling just a bit
intimidated by the talent that came
before her i'm delighted to be here
inheriting the role of queen elizabeth
from two outstanding actresses but
taking on a role of such grandeur with
so much love behind its stars imelda was
feeling like it was all too much even
while shooting the promovid just wait
until she gets deeper into the story
hopefully i look calm collected and
capable my stomach meanwhile is doing
somersaults who are you referring to
camilla why would i care about her
because i care about her
number two and sometimes endings are the
hardest part emma and josh really
struggled with an argument in the last
episode the scene was the first time
they lost their temper with each other
which signified the end of their
relationship she shared it was just so
difficult to get to that place after
becoming so close on set josh and i
especially because the two of them had
never explored that dynamic between the
characters before but josh admitted when
they are angry and hating each other as
soon as they call cut we're laughing and
playing games when the prince of wales
told me he was going away for six weeks
and not taking you
i said that's not very nice
number three the object of conflict
being present in the room changes the
atmosphere i wanted just to play around
a little bit before we actually came to
shoot the scene one way to get your
actors duking it out over a man is to
put that man in rehearsal suddenly the
stakes are through the roof especially
when that man is prince charles i had
him sitting in the middle of the table
between both emma and emeralds he gave a
very interesting direction to them both
only one of you can put your hand on his
emerald got there first with her hand
and it made it super uncomfortable for
emma even though we weren't explicitly
doing it we were battling it out over
him
number four next to the heart is the
breath emmacorin was struggling
breathing because it was like my first
week i actually didn't want to make a
big thing of anything her breathing got
so intense but they were in the middle
of shooting a scene so i just remember
feeling like oh my god i can't breathe
but then they were still rolling luckily
prioritizing her health won out in the
end and then eventually had to be like
please someone help me number five
eating disorders are no joke and emma
was adamant she would get it right emma
corrin definitely did her research on
princess diana she asked if they could
expand the script to make sure the
situations weren't isolated with no
context from all her research and
talking with people who'd experienced it
she said it is all-consuming it is
something that your day ends up
revolving around and it obviously has a
huge strain on you mentally and
emotionally i felt that in order to do
the whole of her story justice i had to
include that i felt a lot for diana this
wedding can't go ahead it'll be a
disaster for everyone
number six hide and seek is an effective
acting challenge we don't film things
chronologically asthma wasn't the only
thing working on emma's physical state
turns out a lost phone can do a lot to
get someone into character he hid the
phone so in the room there are like
three rooms i filled with flowers and
everything else the director did this
every take this just launched emma into
the urgency that was necessary for the
character
number seven that feel when you have to
be cruel and all you want is to spread
love and hugs josh o'connor was so
intense as prince charles that he scared
emma he admitted to feeling just
downright awful about the situation
saying i tend to keep myself to myself
especially on days when it's that kind
of emotional scene he admitted that the
entire time he had to scream in her face
all he wanted to do was give her a hug
and say i'm so sorry
number eight destroying something
beautiful proved to be the wrong choice
how dare these people send us flowers
they have no idea what's going on emma
corrin got so intense playing princess
diana she whipped the flowers around the
room in a frenzy i just like threw these
flowers everywhere and destroyed
effectively the whole room unfortunately
the catharsis was too much i think she
wouldn't let go that much even away from
the public eye there's still the sense
she can't just openly express herself
and it's all the more heartbreaking
number nine the only time not listening
is a good choice in order to hide her
intense emotions a lot of scenes had to
be filmed from the back of olivia
coleman's head but when she was being
filmed from the front the poor woman
couldn't contain her tears upon hearing
the sad things so she needed a
distraction they actually decided to put
an earpiece in her so i just have to try
and tune into the shifting force
number 10 you'd think you'd find energy
in nearly completing a project but no
filming the final scene of season two
matt smith and claire foy were nearing
the end of their time in scotland and
were beaten down smith said filming
wasn't great actually i really found it
difficult by that point we were so
entrenched in making the show we were
just tired it just felt like on the day
we were not landing it and it's
complicated you know there's a lot set
up in there and whether or not prince
philip was faithful smith had to choose
for his character he made the dramatic
choice and with one look foy sparked
panic in smith number 11 choosing to
include this tragedy at all was a daring
move by the creative team but they felt
to honor the story it had to be included
it came with a lot of research and the
opening of old wounds some of the extras
who were invited onto the set of the
aberfan tragedy were there to witness it
the producer said we had a therapist to
help all the people who were recreating
such a horrific scene people who live
there are still traumatized of course
and we found they'd never been offered
help before now we are trying to arrange
more helena bunham carter said of olivia
she's about the most empathetic
individual i know lakes of tears inside
her she can't not cry so she couldn't
listen to me making the speech without
crying and the whole point is that she's
playing the queen who finds it difficult
to express emotion
number 12 goodbyes are never easy
vanessa kirby's last day on set had her
weeping her last scene was on the
buckingham palace set and it was of her
and claire having lunch it was intense
to say goodbye to such a character but
what made it better or worse maybe was
the second cut was called everyone
pulled out disco lights and champagne
music started playing she just bawled
more in typical margaret fashion vanessa
was sobbing and claire was holding it
together completely the same it's always
been between the two of them vanessa
said there's a picture of us and i've
got a completely swollen face from
crying and she just looks completely
fine
number 13. we've all had nights like
this something that helped vanessa kirby
understand margaret was imagining that
she had dark nights of the soul that she
has a darkness to her with something
dangerous lurking just underneath
vanessa kirby said peter had just
written that she does a melancholy dance
but i was like margaret doesn't do just
melancholy further admitting i just
tried to access her pain really
number 14. burn the suit playing the
queen mother in the show really did a
number on victoria hamilton's
self-esteem in season 1. to the point
that she almost burned the bodysuit she
had to wear every day on set every part
of it made her more and more miserable
she'd said every day i had to climb into
that and leave the truck with a large
cup of coffee walking like a farmer oh
why is that they become too emotional i
doubt you'll have that trouble with me
number 15 strong writing leads to great
performances but can also just be so
daunting jillian was feeling incredibly
nervous to film the scenes where
margaret thatcher and queen elizabeth ii
get into a heated fight over apartheid
jillian said those were the scenes i was
most looking forward to and most
dreading at the same time
[Music]
you